wir reden in Deutschland viel über
Deutschland und hier in Berlin
insbesondere in Berlin wird ständig
gesprochen Deutschland muss die Führung
übernehmen und ähnliches man hat
manchmal den Eindruck in Politik in fast
allen Parteien Instink Tanks und so
weiter Deutschland muss Führung
übernehmen und kann Deutschland noch
Führung übernehmen allein
wir sind wirtschaftlich nur so stark
weil wir eine europäischen Binnenmarkt
haben in dem unsere Wirtschaft sich
entwickeln kann
wir können nicht mehr sicherheits- und
Außenpolitik Handelspolitik
Umweltpolitik und vieles andere noch
rein national machen und deswegen müssen
wir Deutschen glaube ich wieder lernen
dass wir
Europa sehr viel stärker glaubwürdig
mitgestalten nicht führen und dass er
auf dieser Grundlage in der Welt eine
Rolle spielen Busch 1 hat Helmut kohlmer
vorgeschlagen Partner in Führung zu sein
und Helmut Kohl hat die gesagt ja ich
akzeptiere als Mitglieder der
Europäischen Gemeinschaft damals das
heißt niemals allein sondern andere
mitzubeziehen um Europa als eine Basis
auch deutscher Stärke zu sehen und nicht
allein davon zu laufen und dabei sehr
isolationistisch zu sein ob es in der
Energiepolitik war in der Vergangenheit
war oder heute in manchen anderen Fragen
brauchen wir mehr oder weniger Europa
Frage ist ja was ist Europa brauchen wir
mehr oder weniger EU das ist ja die
frage ich glaube er meint jetzt oft auch
die EU immer ja genau und das glaube ich
eben nicht dass es die einfach closer
Union braucht also eine immer engere
Verzahnung ich glaube große Krisen
lassen sich brauchen auch eine
nationalstaatliche Antwort das ist für
mich völlig klar wir sind jetzt gerade
auch bei Informationspolitik wie schwer
es ist dann gemeinsam Nenner zu bringen
wir sehen nach wie vor wenn es sich
schon ab hier mit draußen ein
Demokratiedefizit bei der EU Frau von
der Leyen Frau von der Leyen wo ist das
demokratiede Frau von der Leyen wurde
zur kommissionspräsidentin zum Beispiel
gewählt wo man vorher die Auswahl hatte
zwischen Herrn Weber und seinem
sozialdemokratischen kompanion also wir
sehen nach wie vorhin wurde gewählt vom
Europäischen Parlament Demokratie uns
wurde vorher ein spitzen hat namens
Weber mehr bekommen
mehr oh hat sich auch in der
corona-krise glaube ich nicht mit
rumbecker die Verhandlungen mehr mehr
sehen die Frage ist welche Punkte meint
er denn wo wir allein gegen genau ich
sehe die momentan vor allem in der
Migrationspolitik Professor noch mal
gesagt keine Kontrollen heute keine
Asylverfahren außerhalb Europas er sagt
zum Beispiel der österreichischen
Innenminister ist gerade gelesen sieht
es zum Beispiel komplett anders die
Polen selber sehen ist anders wir
brauchen glaube ich bei sie waren
europäisches Fundament wir brauchen aber
auch die Formulierung von deutschen
Interessen das ist ganz normal in der
Welt und dass ich manchmal eben bei der
deutschen Politik Nachholbedarf das ist
ja
im Kern alles alles richtig
nachvollziehbar was sie gerade gesagt
haben aber auf der anderen Seite glaube
festhalten Europa ist noch nicht
vollendet wir haben noch keinen komplett
abgeschlossenen gemeinsamen Markt
Energie ist so ein schönes Beispiel ich
würde mir wünschen nach diesem
Alleingang von Deutschland die
Kernkraftwerke abzuschalten dass wir
einfacher gegebenenfalls auch gern
Energie aus anderen europäischen Ländern
beziehen können dann hätten wir
wahrscheinlich die ganze Menge
Diskussionen über das heizungsgesetz und
andere
Bereiche könnten das in entspannter
führen das ist das eine müssen wir uns
auch ehrlich machen das ist unter dem
Stichwort ja goldplating Deutschland hat
ganz ganz viel an europäischen Rahmen
gesetzten in einer Form übernommen die
einen extrem darstellen was andere
europäische gemacht haben das heißt wir
müssen nicht immer Europa Politik dann
so auslegen dass dann auch ein Stück
weit Europa Verdrossenheit wo wir sagen
die europame was beschlossen wurde mal
reinguckt und das was Europa beschlossen
hat dann ist die Auslegung die
Deutschland gemacht hat die extremste
die am meisten ja Wirtschaft schadet
oder die haben unsozialsten
gegebenenfalls ist
stolz drauf hat sie gerade für gesagt
wir über erfüllen das sind enorm wir
werden genau was anderes steht im
Koalitionsvertrag wir werden das
verhindern dass wir über erfüllen aber
letzte Woche wäre das gesagt hat weiß
ich nicht so das heißt also auch da
national Interessen natürlich definieren
aber wir müssen uns darüber im Klaren
sein wenn wir China wenn du über Amerika
reden auch über Russland werden nur als
Europa gemeinsam erfolgreiche Antworten
geben können und das sollte auch der
Kern irgendwo der Europapolitik sein
dass wir gucken was wir miteinander
gestalten können und wo wir diesen Markt
noch weiter verfolgenden können dann
haben wir einen richtigen Weg wir reden
jetzt darüber dass Freihandel einer der
wirtschaftstreiber in der Zukunft sein
muss mit anderen Regionen in der Welt
dann müssen wir gucken dass wir das was
war auf europäischer Ebene haben
natürlich auch im Wohlstand in den
eigenen nationalen Interesse auch tiefer
gestalten
sie sind dran ja möchte ich meine eigene
these begründen dürfen
erstens sie haben gute Beispiele genannt
wo Europa hilfreich war ich habe 2002
beim verfassungskondent beantragt das
ist von Berlin und bei Ursel abgelehnt
worden in Pandemie Fragen Europa
bestimmte Zuständigkeiten zu geben nun
ist er nach ihrer Auffassung gescheitert
Europa in eine Frage wo die
Nationalstaaten diesen Europa keine
Rechte gegeben haben sie hatte nämlich
keine Kompetenzen und im übrigen war es
so dass dennoch die Europäische Union
Zeit genau am August geliefert hat mit
den Impfstoffen mit viel Ärger drum und
dran und Hindernissen in den
Mitgliedstaaten so dass sie keine Region
der Welt gleichzeitig reichen und arme
Länder in gleichermaßen mit Impfstoffen
verseucht war eine ungeheure Leistung
eine ungeheuerin wurde zu viel Impfstoff
eingebaut ja das ist genau das ist
nein ich bin oder auch versucht lieber
mehr einzukaufen wie viele andere Länder
ist auch getan haben als zu wenig
einkaufen dann hätte man gesagt warum
hat er nicht mehr eingekauft also an
solchen Stuss zu reden aber wir haben
hier Menschen lassen sich doch einmal
Ausreden
das muss man doch sehen ist eine
ungeheure Erfolg gewesen der weltweit so
gesehen wird und wir müssen weiterhin
das ist nicht allein national gemacht
haben das wäre eine Katastrophe gewesen
wenn wir das allein national gemacht
werden dann werden die Rumänen und
andere abgesoffen dass wenn die
Italiener nicht geholfen haben wir
müssen sehen dass unsere wirtschaftliche
Stärke auf diese Binnenmarkt beruht
diese Binnenmarkt ist sogar so gut dass
das sein dass das Land aus der ihre
Zeitung kommt ohne mitentscheiden zu
können alle Regeln Europäischen Union
übernommen hat das in diesem tätig sein
können einmal einschreiben lassen sie
haben gesagt das ist ein riesen Erfolg
war das heißt sie sagen auch heute noch
mit Blick auf ihn zurückliegenden Jahre
es ist pandemiemanagement und auch der
übereinkauf die Impfstoffe ein riesen
Erfolg weil man kann sie auch immer
besser machen ist allein nationale
Zuständigkeit gewesen
allein national Europäische Union hat
nur übernommen dass die Grenzen
wieder offen waren und dass die
Impfstoffe in gleicher Weise verteilt
worden sind
besser gemacht bitte die uhd ist besser
gemacht als wir hatten weil sie es
gemacht hat und wir sind dadurch
rausgekommen mit den Impfstoffen das ist
doch ohne Zweifel so dass man das
gemacht hat wenn das jeder national
gemacht hat als erspart noch bergamon
und mit Schutzausrüstung liefern wollen
war das eine bessere Weg also jeder der
eigenständig gemacht haben das ist doch
ich bin erschüttet muss ich sagen Herr
Dr Kissler und wir müssen wir müssen
weiterhin sehen
wo ist denn Fragen der Sanktion jetzt
mit Russland will das nicht gemeinsam
europäische Politik wäre das ist keine
europäischen Politik geben
die nehme ich mir mehr als Entscheidung
hat in der sicherheits- und Außenpolitik
das heißt mehr Europa in dieser Frage in
manchen Punkten wo es wichtig ist in
Europa noch nicht genügend ausgestaltet
aber der europäische Binnenmarkt ist
gesund ein riesiger Flüchtlinge die
verteilungsflüchtlinge ist eine Frage wo
wir Deutschen es verhindert haben dass
die Berechtigung nämlich mit Mehrheit zu
entscheiden nicht eingesetzt wurden
sich auf die deutsche Position beziehen
wir müssen jetzt auf einmal Antworten
lassen weil unter anderem ist der Satz
gefallen reden sie nicht so einen
Schluss darauf muss ich sehr antworten
dürfen Frechheit ja ja toleranter Mensch
würde ich jetzt hier schon mal jemand
das Studio verlassen ja ähm aber ich
bleibe ja die Fächer und
aber ich glaube die EU hat die Knie ist
knirscht im gebälkte oh ich glaube das
sehen auch viele Beobachter dass wir
gerade was die Migrationspolitik angehen
und selber im Weg stehen dass die
Verteilung nicht klappt das auch
aufgrund der poolfaktoren von
Deutschland
Schutz der Außengrenzen nicht
funktioniert dass wir nach wie vor
Schengen letzten Endes nicht einhalten
muss ich ihn glaube ich nicht erklären
und dass die Tatsache dass viele
Menschen sich von den Brüssel an
Straßburg Entscheidung überhaupt nicht
mitgenommen fühlen nicht hinweg zu
diskutieren ist ihr Fazit zur
corona-pandemie ja ich würde sagen ja
3-4 plus also mehr ist es nicht teure
Verträge gemacht mit Pfizer sehr viel
Geld ausgegeben man musste vieles
wegwerfen ich sagte überhaupt nicht dass
man gar nicht hätte machen können oder
Frauen Ansagen können geht schon
irgendwie vorbei aber es hätte besser
gehen können
in England hat funktioniert mit den
Impfungen erinnern Sie sich eigentlich
alles hat funktioniert
nämlich immer zu spät dran an der Frage
England hatte England ist da gewesen
nicht funktioniert
die Briten sind heute in riesen Briten
kann in einer wirtschaftlichen
Katastrophe und sie sind wieder in einer
wirtschaftlichen katast
ROP Schottland Nordirland Wales und
England und sie hat eine schneller kann
man nicht anders sagen hat heute wieder
die ganze meinungsbreite gezeigt die es
gibt von Corona Pandemie Management
furchtbar zu erstklassik so wollen wir
sie haben und wenn wir wollen sehen wir
uns morgen wieder danke an meine Gäste
das hat mir großen Spaß gemacht und über
Tieren sie zu Hause bitte weiter